good morning everyone i'm going to open
the public hearing on hb 1614
in one second because i just realized
so
um i will call up
representative jess edwards who's asked
um for the record uh i'm representative
jess edwards representing
rockingham district four auburn chester
and sandown here to introduce uh hb 1614
to the committee
i'm the
chair chair of division iii finance
we have financial jurisdiction over the
sununu center
um i was also appointed along with your
chairman to the
sysc
replacement and closure committee
where we looked into things
in that
committee special committee
we went and visited the ag's office and
we spoke to
[Music]
the
senior ag that handles
civil procedure so if we get sued she
gets the cases
and then if we need to prosecute
somebody for poor behavior
the other
senior ag was there and so we didn't
cross talk because they have kind of a
firewall between them
but as we talked about the kinds of
things that they thought we needed to
include
in
the replacement center
they
both
civil procedure and criminal
pursuits were
both very confident that they needed
this bill that there isn't enough
storage of quality digital recordings
because as you can imagine if we need to
defend somebody
we want to have good video evidence and
audio evidence and then if you want to
prosecute one of our employees or
somebody else that's a visitor or guest
you'd still want the evidence so
if you had
mr goulet the commissioner for doit here
and mr weeders who is the
cio for the department of health and
human services what they'd say is that
they already do this so you would get a
little bit of conflicting
um
testimony and just just to deconflict it
a little bit they they currently are
recording and storing for two years and
so we wrote on
uh on line 11
that the retention of the data should be
a minimum length of time to
make sure that justice is served
and
in the financial analysis they assume
that that would be seven years because
there's a fiscal note with us so so in
the fiscal note you'll see 42 000
to build out the storage architecture to
to keep these images
for a longer period of time
the reason we didn't put seven years on
line 11 is because federal and state law
can change over time and it may be
appropriate to keep them 14 years or 20
years or or whatever so we we didn't
have to keep changing the laws
on line
9 and 10 you'll see that the the
recordings have to capture
the actions of one person and
interactions between two or more people
we didn't specify what kind of people
those are those could be uh
guests of the facility
uh it could be
our own employees and and so we had a
lobbyist suggest to us
that we specifically call out and say
including law enforcement
and so if you hear that i just want to
tell you i i thought about that i just
think that would be redundant because
you know people are people i think
there's a 60 song about that
so we want them to maintain up time of
which is they don't currently have a
standard so this would establish
standard so
and with that madam chair thank you i'll
representative grossman
so be nice my my sisters are in the back
room so be
gentle to me
thank you madam chair
um thank you for coming uh
representative edwards to present this
who can access
the video you may have said that
but who
can access
these
videos the
the act this bill doesn't specifically
refer to the access control
as i mentioned they
already have a system in place uh the
reliability and the length of time is
really kind of the issue between the
status quo and what we're proposing
so uh so i i didn't touch the access
control issues because i believe it's
already covered uh in the current system
and i do think
that you know there is a reference here
to requiring
privacy
pursuant to federal and state laws or
regulations
uh that doesn't that's that's related to
the areas of control and not the
access to the images
so it's not complete i think if you
wanted to amend this to be more specific
i wouldn't have any issue with that
but because i didn't pursue it i don't
know if it would be redundant with some
are there any further questions i i have
one further answer to give sure um
there's um
a bill that i think has excellent
prospects that will establish one within
the department of health and human
services
uh a security and i.t governance
committee who will be responsible
for ensuring
privacy and they'll be doing it through
establishment of various policies for it
security and privacy
and if if the department doesn't already
have a specific access control privacy
to protect private uh
access control policy to protect privacy
i i'm sure that would be one of the
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
on that same line as the
retaining a minimum length of time as
justice may require
it talks about some provisions in the
rsa which is
relating to
get this information so that they can
put it in their court case
and is that um
the use of the recording um
in court cases is the main objective
um of this bill and
and having that access so that they can
um
um have proof of what what occurred in
that
situation so that they can
obtain justice from the judicial
branch is that um
is that
my correct understanding of the kind of
thrust of this bill or you you know i i
thank you for the question uh
representative
i uh i would say that depending on who
you talk to you'd get slightly different
answers when you say this the primary
purpose is for uh evidence for the court
cases you know there's two types there's
the civil procedure where we get sued
for damages then there's criminal
in case somebody's violated the law so
in either court
scenario this evidence would be
available and subject to just uh
discovery
i think another person could come in and
say no no no the real reason that we do
this is because when people know that
they're being watched and there's
evidence they modify their behavior and
we pro it's a this is a prevention tool
as much as it is
uh
evidentiary
thank you sure
are there any further questions
uh representative
grossman
or representative long which one had
you called me representative grossman
okay
so i had submitted a
a bill a few sessions ago for videos
audio and video surveillance in group
homes
and
that
there was
a lot of
privacy
concerns
so in this bill
do you discuss
placement so where
cameras
in terms of
privacy
of these kids
camera placement in terms of like
we we did common areas but this is a
different situation than a group home
was that discussed uh thank you for the
question i i okay i i would say that
this um
the video and audio recording in
detention centers is
um
an
industry in itself where there are
consultants that come in and and what
this bill would require them to do
uh particularly in a replacement
scenario where we build something new
is is to do an architectural review of
all of the angles to make sure that in
the hallways and the kitchens and the
dining rooms you know everywhere where
people can in the counseling rooms
probably they may want to turn off audio
but
i i don't know but but there will be uh
i'm sure consultants that are brought in
and and do a a map a mapping of the
facility that where you wouldn't put
this is uh
in those places that are protected uh by
privacy law and federal state regulate
and other regulations
um
like such as a bathroom if somebody's
using the the facilities you're you're
just not going to record that um and
there there are probably other
exceptions that are exempt
does that answer your question
all right oh and you mentioned group
homes
if you look
at
line four
it reads each facility paid for in whole
or in part with general funds and used
by law enforcement county sheriffs or
state police
so that certainly would include the
sununu center but it would not
probably include group homes so your
bill is not redundant it would be
complementary
do you have any follow-ups okay
thank you madam chair thank you
representative taking my question so
each back to line four
a secure out-of-state placement would we
we would require
um videoing
uh thank you
representative i i would i my answer to
that and again i'm not an attorney is uh
that this is new hampshire law and would
govern all facilities in new hampshire i
think your question refers to whether or
not we contract out support to
out-of-state locations and i don't think
they'd be covered by this law
but this law might inform the
contracting process where we would have
to negotiate with vermont or maine or
whatever
this would probably uh
want to
want to be a requirement but this
particular bill would not require our
putting it into contract language and i
so what i think you've done is i think
you've discovered a possible hole
that that maybe
an amendment could fill
so so
uh follow-up for me so so your your
your bill is
is new hampshire only yeah okay uh and
then the other follow-up if i may
um
it doesn't say who pays for the videoing
so like let's say that nashua is
children home there's somebody being
detained there
um they're in new hampshire they're
they're we're required for video
who pays would would the state be
responsible for paying state facilities
putting the videos in
and the private entity were contracted
with would be responsible would that
would be a requirement of the contract
[Music]
okay so there there's a clear bright
line i think in this of what we pay for
the uh what we wouldn't pay for is is
not in this bill so so the group homes
as i mentioned before i think the group
homes would be outside of this bill and
the other bill being represented or
presented by the representative could be
complementary to this but this is just
general funds
would have to be used to pay for the
sununu centers for example and anywhere
it also said anywhere where we want to
securely detain miners
so
so i don't know that as a routine
practice we
the state securely detains minors at
group homes i i don't think we do that
okay
uh very good thank you
are there any further questions
representative desamond
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
considering some of the other questions
i'm
trying to answer them in my own head
and
on um
line four it says each facility paid for
wouldn't that
also
therefore include
if we
outsourced to another state and that
facility has
video cameras in it wouldn't that
protect
the state of new hampshire
in allowing those facilities to use
those cameras as we would
since we paid those facilities
yeah you're taking care of our youth
thank you for the question i think
you're
you guys are on to an excellent edge
case
scenario that i did not anticipate
i've i've always conceived this to be
uh new hampshire controlled facilities
but the way that sentence reads and i
i'll
i'll be a weasel and say that i had ols
help me with the drafting so
uh
the um
i i just didn't work through the
scenario in my head when we contracted
out and maybe i know mr ribson
representing dcyf is coming up so maybe
he could tell us what he thinks i think
it would be smart contracting to make it
a requirement but
um
i i'd i'd like to take sort of an
another opportunity while i'm talking
anyways
is uh i did not include body cameras
they haven't used body cameras there
wasn't a request for body cameras by the
ag
um and so it it's silent on body cameras
and i don't know
what this committee would want to do
about that i
i'd say take a baby step and just make
sure we got the
okay are there any further questions
all right seeing none thank you so much
thank you for your time
and i'm gonna ask director ripson to
come up and maybe address some of these
questions
there we go
good morning members of the committee
joe ripson director dcyf thank you for
uh hearing me today good to see
everybody this morning yes we're not we
didn't officially take a position on
this bill um
i'm here primarily just to provide
information but i heard some questions
brought up last time that might be
helpful for me to provide some
information on um so a couple things
currently sysc is the only facility in
the entire state of new hampshire or
anywhere
in the country that takes detained and
committed kids from new hampshire
there are no detained and committed kids
in private facilities there are no
detained committed kids in other states
there are kids who are in residential
programs for other purposes but they've
not been detained or committed by the
court or they've been maybe released on
parole or what's called administratively
released that's when we determine that a
child but needs are best suited in a
residential program rather than in sysc
so the questions about this applying to
other settings really don't apply to
today's state of course there's
conversations around the future of
detention and commitment in new
hampshire and should that future look
different that answer would be different
two in terms of what we already record
about two and a half years ago when
when we started hearing about this
litigation coming forward we took a look
at the existing video surveillance
system within sysc and found that it
wasn't
up to where we wanted it to be the
quality was low the camera placement was
not capturing everything we wanted to
capture
and the department made a significant
investment in putting in a new very high
quality camera system which captures
everything in the building everything on
the perimeter of the building
except for
most bedrooms and i say most because
there are a couple that have cameras for
when a young person is on a suicide
watch so that we can watch that
and that is allowable under federal and
state law
and um bathrooms uh most of the
bathrooms that's why i see are
single-use bathrooms single-use showers
um if a child is on something like in
those instances of a child's own some
type of watch status where we're worried
about them trying to harm themselves the
staff actually will go in with them
which i know is not a comfortable
thought but we have to make sure that
we're safe for kids but we don't record
inside of there
so i think those are the basic two
questions that came up i'm happy to
answer others if people have or go
representative de simone
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking this question
um can you talk a little bit about
storage
yeah so currently
um
the video storage so currently i think
it's around two years worth of storage
but actually
up until
months ago
when a litigation hold was put into
place it wasn't even kept for that long
it was only kept if there was an
incident and then it would be held now
the problem with the standard like that
is that sometimes somebody brings up an
allegation
later than we realize and then that
video would have been gone
so at this point at this exact moment
because there's a litigation hold
nothing is being destroyed or eliminated
but i do think changing to a system
where it's held i think the reason the
department assumed seven years was
because that's i believe the statute of
limitations
moving to a point where you hold this
video for a longer period of time
representative long
thank you madam chair thank you mr
ripson um
okay with respect to uh detained and
committed
uh there's no scenario with respect to a
mental health facility or
a substance use facility where somebody
would be detained or committed not for
the purpose of detention and commitment
now if the court orders detention and
commitment that's a separate standard
and the only place where they would go
is sysc right now
lots of kids go to programs like that
but that's based on treatment needs and
based on an identified you know need to
have a child reside in some place to
have their you know their needs met
i'll follow up with do you think that
that should be specified in the bill
as i it's clear to me as you know the
person who does this the way that it's
written because it talks about applying
to facilities for detention and
commitment
which to me reads it's only sysc today
but it leaves room that if in a future
state some other facilities identified
for detention and commitment that this
would apply to that facility
so i think for my purposes it makes
sense but i can understand people who
don't have the same exposure to this
work that i do on a day-to-day basis
might not might not follow that the same
way
okay
uh and then
uh
the follow-up i make
with respect to um with
respect to out of state are you in
agreement that
we should just concentrate on the state
of new hampshire right now i think given
that the only facility that's used is in
the state of new hampshire um i think
that's the right place to put our focus
you know during the committee process
around the replacement and closure of
sysc there was a lot of discussion
around the importance of making sure
that kids stay as local as possible to
their communities because
when kids go to sysc it's very
infrequent that they're there for very
long they're going to reintegrate with
their families they're going to
reintegrate with their communities and
having long distances makes that harder
representative de simone
thank you madam chair as a follow-up to
my prior question concerning storage do
you feel that it would be necessary
for your department to specify in the
law the seven years
i don't i don't think so i think the way
that we read it was was that you know
it's as necessary for you know you know
litigation criminal justice all those
types of purposes i don't remember the
exact language in here but that's how we
read it and that's how we got to the
seven years so if at some point the
statute of limitation changed or
something like that we would be able to
ex change the the time period that the
records would be retained thank you very
much
all right seeing none thank you so much
for the information thank you okay so
i'm going to close the public hearing on
hb 1614 and we'll be back at 10 30 for
okay
so i'm going to open the public hearing
on 1612 and i will call up rep james
spelaine
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee
i bring forward hb 1612
fn as an attempt to stop the abuse of
the system
allow limited and crucial dcyf resources
to be invested in true cases where
children are in danger
and to allow the state to apply
penalties to those who make malicious
and intentional false complaints
i do not know if the system has become
more weaponized and abused lately or if
i have only come to notice it through my
constituents
but what i once thought was an
occasional false complaint made with
knowingly malicious intent has become
more commonplace
i'm sorry to say i hear it most often
with regards to divorces where one party
is having friends love interests or
family make anonymous complaints against
the other party
to gain some perceived advantage in
court regarding custody
i know of one person right now who's
been in the divorce process for three
years with four young children
and who has had six separate complaints
filed by the new love interest of their
former partner
it's for that reason that i include the
ability for the court to appoint a
guardian ad litem to be able to
recognize a pattern of malicious and
abusive complaints being made
in any situation where there's custody
involved a divorce situation
the bill does not remove the protections
and i repeat does not remove the
protections that are afforded to those
making a complaint in any way
it changes the concept of anonymous
reports to one of confidential reports
to any of you
who have friends or relatives in the
police force you'll recognize that the
protections afforded to confidential
informants is extremely strong
the rest of you probably recognize the
protections afforded to juvenile records
protections in this case are just as
strong as it would take an absolute
proof of malicious and harmful intent to
unmask any identity of anyone who makes
a complaint
for that reason i don't think that this
bill would ever affect a first-time
complainer it would have to show a
pattern of false complaints before that
person becomes unmasked to try to find
out who's making the false complaints
as such this bill will mainly target
those repeat abusers of the system
where the pattern of definitive
malicious and harmful intent can be
proven
finally the bill provides for penalties
after someone has been proven to have
made malicious and deliberately harmful
complaints
i have a handout from the united states
bureau the children's bureau
which is located at childwelfare.gov
and it shows the landscape across all 50
states and puerto rico for both failing
to report and for falsely reporting
29 states and puerto rico all have
penalties in place in varying forms and
amounts to address false reports new
hampshire has none
the closest we have in new hampshire is
filing a false police report but a
report made directly to dcyf is not
technically a filed police report so
court action is doubtful
the state would not be able to reach the
burden of proof on that that it was a
filed police false police report and
there's no law saying they can't make a
false report to dcyf
in addition when complaints may be taken
completely anonymously there's no way to
identified a repeated abuser even should
a pattern be recognized
and every time a false report is made
even when there's a pattern of false
reports dcyf has no other option but to
fully investigate the report
that takes valuable resources away from
other cases and we end up with
situations like we have with missing
child harmony montgomery
i will give you uh the handout that i
have to the secretary so you can all get
copies i didn't have time to make copies
for everyone this morning and it's a
pretty
thick report
but i ask you to support hb 1612 fn and
to help deter malicious and harmful
false reports in new hampshire while
allowing dcyf to focus their very
crucial resources on the cases where
children are in actual danger and not
being used as collateral pawns by
selfish adults
and with that i'll take questions if you
have them
are there any questions
so i have one yes ma'am so who pays for
the gal if the parents can't afford to
pay for the gal
well if the parents can't afford it i
think if you're aware with with the
court they usually assign the the cost
of the gal to one parent or the other
based on whoever's more financially able
to do it or sometimes they split it uh
if neither parent was able to pay for it
and
uh the court
again it's an option the court can
appoint it it's not saying the court
must appoint it
so the judge and his wisdom would be
able to decide
in my opinion
whether one's necessary
and if one was necessary for the
protection of one parent one would hope
that that parent found a means to pay
for the gal and if not i imagine it
would probably fall in a state
are you aware that in the bill it says
shall not may
it was supposed to be a may and i missed
that
are there any further questions
thank you uh madam chair uh thank you
representative
now this this uh these reports just um
refer to neglect and abuse
yes sir
okay so
uh
and a follow-up if i may
uh so with respect to a casa or
appointment that's that's at no cost
correct
i imagine that i believe that casas are
at no cost right okay
uh and is there
is there
to follow up certainly is there a point
where
it becomes
we start to realize that it's being
malicious i mean is it two times is it
three times is it four times i think
that the experts at dcyf would be able
to recognize the pattern better than i
would um i can definitely say that six
times i think you've already established
a pattern when they've had to
investigate six times to find nothing
and they're still getting calls um
sometimes it might be two times i doubt
that any first time call would ever
establish a pattern it's one time
and uh follow us one if i may thank you
uh and this is
this is not only for
parties involved this could be a
mother-in-law or a grandfather
i have seen this weaponized against
political officials when somebody didn't
like what they were doing i've even
heard of it being used by a neighbor who
was disgruntled about the way that their
neighbors were behaving and made a call
into dcyf anonymously it's being
weaponized more and more
i think
but as i said in my testimony
i don't know if that pattern always
existed and i'm just noticing it more or
if it's become an aspect of social media
and the the spread of people deciding
that they can try to get the other
person by using the state against them
very good thank you
are there any further questions
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
it seems to me that this is
subjects i guess one of them is um in in
divorce proceedings you should have a
guardian item and the other one is
um if you're making false reports there
should be something
that a rule that you're breaking is
there a connection that i'm missing
between the two or is
is one of them if if let's say for
example we did not agree that you should
always have to have a guardium at
lightham could we still keep
the um
the bill
um having punishments for making false
reports to dcyf and it and it still
stand on its own kind of a thing i see
where your question's going and yes it
does stand on its own i only added the
guardian ad litem as a
um
disconnected third party to recognize
the pattern of abuse
and if that was something that
that um
because the guardian ad litem if if
you're in a divorce situation which is
where i think it happens most often uh
my thought and and the
answers i got from some people that i
talked to was that the guardian ad litem
if the court decided to appoint one
would be able to see having known the
children and interviewed them that these
reports had a false malicious intent to
them and be able to end on a sooner wait
not rather than waiting for six
complaints they'd be able to see after
the second one or the third one that
this is bogus
and be able to say we need to put a stop
to these false complaints and get on
with the the
case in in court
for the divorce
so it's it's related via the the false
complaint being made
and as i said only one part of it is the
divorce situation where the complaints
are made there are a lot of reports made
that's that yeah no no follow-up yeah
yeah um so
thank you for for taking this follow-up
it seems to me that the um language
uh regarding guardian items is only
in divorce proceedings it specifically
states correct
divorce proceedings and
it would be in cases that are brought
pursuant to this chapter so
um
my
in my reading of it the dcyf would have
to make a judgment on whether or not
something was um
malicious
and then they would
recommend that charges be filed and then
when the charges were filed the case
would exist before that the case doesn't
really exist and then
they would um
the gal would do the research for the
court to find out whether or not this um
yes possible if
the complaints are made and there's
currently a co-existing
situation for custody which could be
inside or outside of a divorce
proceeding but if there's children
involved in a custody situation and the
complaints are being made to try to
influence that then the gal
could once the determination was made by
dcyf that there was a pattern of abuse
here and they want to unmask the person
and have the gal look at it they could
have the gl gal look into it before they
decide to unmask the person
and and decide who's actually making
those anonymous complaints the gal could
look into it and see is this truly
malicious are the children being harmed
more by the complaints
than
the situation that they're living in
because children are harmed by the false
complaints
are you all set
yes thank you are there any further
questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you
up next is um director ribson from dcyf
good morning members of the committee
joe ripsom director dcyf
uh thank you for hearing my uh testimony
this morning in opposition to this bill
is drafted um i do appreciate the the
the issue that um
that the sponsor brought forward as
being one that
that is worthy of the state thinking
about um we do see situations where
people's
attempt to weaponize the child
protection system in private custodial
matters
sometimes they're divorces sometimes
they're not divorces but we do see it
happen
we also do see situations where we
believe people are making complaints
that are
unwarranted but nevertheless trigger an
investigation because
for us if we get an allegation
that if proven true would be abuse or
neglect we must screen it in we must
investigate
um
which means some people who know how to
make craft allegations could make false
allegations and trigger an investigation
even if it's something that's not
warranted
and we would think it would be somewhat
of a dangerous position for us not to
follow up on something like that
so i understand the intent of this and i
think this is actually a space where
folks could
could come to some solutions to try to
improve that aspect of the system it
does waste resources it has folks
digging into problems that aren't really
problems and it is bad for kids and
families to have them scared of the
child protection system unnecessarily
all the time
at the same time my biggest concern with
this bill is the elimination of
anonymous reporting
while i understand the intent here is to
make sure that people aren't making
false reports and to be able to identify
who are making repeated reports we often
get anonymous reports that are warranted
that are founded
um and while i would prefer and we ask
everybody who calls to identify
themselves and tell them that we'll keep
their name confidential unless told by a
court that we have to share it and that
does happen sometimes
a lot of people still choose to report
anonymously and i can't imagine a
situation where we get a call you know
some of these are pretty horrific calls
right somebody's a victim of domestic
violence there's something horrible
happening to their child they're afraid
to identify themselves
and i can't imagine getting that call
and the caller this the screener on our
side saying sorry you won't tell me your
name so we're not going to go out and
look at this um it's just it's not
something that i think is
good for kids i think we have to come up
with ways to
address that issue without completely
eliminating anonymous reporting
in terms of the first part right the
part around the appointment of a gal i
think there's lots of practical
implications that the committee's tapped
onto that need to be figured out i don't
think it's a bad idea having an
independent person look
in custodial disputes and divorces
especially where it looks like the child
protection system is being weaponized
but figuring out how to do that is
is complicated who's going to pay for it
i would say um i'd want to be very
careful that dcyf doesn't get put into
the role of becoming that expert for
those cases our role is abuse or neglect
we have to focus on abuse or neglect and
when you get into the realm of talking
about best interest of kids and weighing
parental rights between two people who
are legally fit to be parents that's not
really dcyf's role
and then finally the last section of
this around
the
potential for false reporting and
making that a misdemeanor there are many
states in the country that do that
already i don't have a particular
objection to it i would just say
something for the committee to consider
is you know potential chilling effect
how do we message that how do we talk
about that to make sure that folks
understand that making a good faith
report is absolutely a protected
activity and it's only if you're
intentionally trying to weaponize the
child protection system that you'd be at
risk and with that i'm happy to take
questions okay so i have a quick
question um
because it does state in here that casa
would be but i thought casa didn't do
parenting cases like that i thought they
were strictly for a child that is in in
an abuse or neglect case with dcyf not
um and and they don't do
family court as far as
divorces or or custody
whatever
that's absolutely right they only take
on cases of child abuse and neglect
that's under you know their own
structure their own statute they are
mostly volunteers they receive some
money through the courts and they
receive some money through us for
training but it's overwhelmingly
volunteers that do that work
um and i don't think they would see this
as being part of their their mandate and
mission um i think the way that it's i'm
not sure the way that it's written
actually says it has to be a casa is as
a gal and there are jls that are not
casas but i do think that's something
that should be clarified
okay representative ocala
thank you and thank you for taking the
question in these states that have
punishments
um for
knowingly trying to weaponize dcyf um
are those
um
do those states allow or do you know if
those states allow for anonymous
reporting
and if
they
do
is there a way
like
recordings of the of the phone call and
the phone number which the police could
then use to
de-mask someone if
um
if it was found that they were in
violation of the crime good question um
i'm not sure what happens in most of
those states you know as you heard it's
actually a majority of states that do
have some statute on the books around
that
i can tell you one of the big
differences between the state where i
previously worked that i currently
worked is that in new jersey we did
record all the calls to intake in new
hampshire we do not do that
that is a way of being able to identify
folks even if you're taking anonymous
calls and establish patterns um i don't
that's not something that i would be
opposed to but there would obviously be
fiscal and practical implications around
establishing that here because we don't
are there any further questions for the
director representative long
thank you madam chair uh thank you
director ripson uh
in your experience
have you identified uh
reports that were malicious or uh false
you know we've seen we it it doesn't
happen all the time that it would cross
that threshold it's pretty infrequent
but we have seen them and actually
the times that i see them
oftentimes are the same cases that i'm
hearing from your colleagues on right
one of your colleagues is hearing from a
constituent who's unhappy that they
don't think dcyf is doing the right
thing
we get a call from one of your
colleagues take a look at this and you
know we never share the information with
with with your colleagues because it's
confidential but we meet with those
folks and oftentimes it's these
custodial disputes where
there might be a difference of opinion
between what's the best thing to do for
a child or the best way to raise a child
but that's not abuse for neglect and i
think part of that comes down to this
there's a i think there's a
misperception of what dcyf's role is in
the state right that folks
have an opinion that we're supposed to
be out there kind of policing all
parenting interactions and deciding
what's best for all kids and that's not
our role our role is very limited to
abuse and neglect which is a pretty high
standard and parents have a lot of
leeway to determine what's the best way
to raise a child and when you have two
parents who are separated you'll often
have two parents who have different
ideas about the best way to raise a
child and that's that's the line that i
try to be very careful of of us not
creeping into because we
we're not authorized to do that and
we're also not resourced and built to do
that right okay
with respect to
um anonymous reporting
in your professional experience would
you suspect that there would be a
decrease in reporting if i had to give
my name address phone number
yeah there probably would be there
probably some folks who would not be
comfortable making a report if they were
not allowed to make it anonymously
and i i'd be worried about what we might
miss under the circumstances sometimes
those reports are are reports where
there's some really bad stuff happening
sure very good thank you
people are fearful right a domestic
violence case for instance um
if someone is actually still in the home
enabled and able to get out i think that
would that not create
a larger problem
i i think that's probably the number one
scenario that i think about where
anonymous reporting is appropriately
used
um i'll tell you so
there are situations where i think it's
inappropriate i personally think that
professional reporters should always
give their names our law doesn't require
that but we try to educate folks we have
good colleagues through the know and
tell process
which is our child advocacy centers
granite state children's alliance run
that where they really encourage folks
to identify themselves and talk to them
about the confidential process
but in almost all instances you want to
know who the reporter is because you
want to be able to follow up and dig
deeper and the phone call that somebody
receives that intake is not going to be
as deep as a follow-up conversation with
an investigator who's been able to look
at other facts and circumstances and
follow up so we really do want people to
use their names i would just be afraid
to say
that we'll never accept a report where
somebody doesn't identify themselves
are there any further questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you
up next is richard head
he's asked for two minutes to speak to
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is richard head i'm
the government affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch i did submit written
testimony on the online
submission
process
it's a fairly simple request
dealing with the effective date of 60
days we're asking that it be moved to
january 1 2023
and the reason being a statute that
governs effective dates of legislation
rsa 14 colon 9-a
provides that every law affecting
judicial practice and procedure or
establishing or eliminating criminal
prohibitions shall take effect on the
january 1 following passage this bill
creates a new rsa 169 c31 roman
paragraph 2 which creates a new criminal
penalty
and the reason we care is there's a
process after the legislative session
dealing with a whole host of changes to
legislation if you look at it just at
the criminal provisions
there's the j-1 program where we have
the uniform charge table where every
criminal charge is listed on a on a
table that is used by law enforcement
when they are charging individuals to
make sure that we have consistency and
then it ties into the odyssey database
that the court maintains and anytime
there's even a minor tweak to any line
in the criminal code or any statute that
has a criminal provision the uniform
charge table has to be modified and
updated and our odyssey database has to
be modified to match it exactly
and over the course of a legislative
session there's several
hundred at least changes that are made
and it just takes a great deal of time
to make sure we it gets done
it's done with the department of safety
department of justice in our office and
and trying to make sure that everyone is
exactly right because it affects how
charges are made
so we simply ask that the uh there be an
amendment to change uh section five of
the bill effective date to 60 days after
passage
and then with regard and just
since there was a question about the gal
um it does say shallow point there is
not a gal fund um so there is no state
fund currently
there previously had been it is no
longer in existence so there is no state
fund
that does pay for
gals when the parties are unable to pay
i mean with that i'd be happy to answer
any questions
so i just i just have one question so
then if
even if we changed it to may would that
then
an unfair some cases at a at almost an
unfair advantage or
right so
i mean just because you're poor doesn't
mean that
you know you shouldn't have a gal in
that case right so but if we're only
going to allow those who have the money
to pay i i just feel like there's a big
kind of conflict there where we're
leaving a bunch of people out if we're
you know the
the gal fund was useful um in currently
if the parties are unable to pay i mean
that is a consideration the court takes
into account when
appointing a gal and the parties are
unable to pay there is no other funding
source so
there are certainly cases in which
a gal may be appropriate that do not get
appointed a gal i won't disagree with
that
okay thank you very much thank you very
much
up next is um will estrada
from parental rights start or got a is
it lewisville virginia lovettsville
virginia to speak for five minutes in
good morning madam chair members of the
new hampshire house of representatives
children and family law committee my
name is will estrada i am an attorney a
husband a dad and the president of
parentalrights.org we're a nationwide
nonprofit that has advocated for
protecting children by empowering
parents for the last 15 years
i want to speak today about why
representative spelaine's bill hb 1612
is so important this bill will replace
anonymous reporting to dcyf's hotline
with confidential reporting anonymous
reporting refers to the ability of a
caller to make an allegation of abuse or
neglect and not leave any identifying
information
with confidential reporting dcyf still
keeps the caller's identity a secret but
the caller must provide the name and
other identifying information and
importantly the bill states quote the
department shall inform the complainant
that should the complaint be made
maliciously or with intent to harm that
the identity of the complainer shall not
be kept sealed end quote and the bill
provides civil and criminal penalties if
a caller quote knowingly make false
statements of suspected child abuse end
quote hb 1612 will significantly reduce
if not eliminate false and malicious
reports of child abuse and neglect
thereby protecting innocent children and
families and allowing dcyf to focus
attention on children who are truly
victims of abuse and neglect
what is the cost of an unnecessary
government investigation the director of
dcyf alluded to this and i want to
direct you to a law review article by
doreen lamberle coleman entitled
storming the castle to save the children
the ironic costs of a child welfare
exception to the fourth amendment this
was published in the william mary law
review
in 2005. she wrote the following quote
in the name of saving children from the
harm that their parents and guardians
are thought to pose states ultimately
cause more harm to many more children
than they ever help in 2002 for example
the states conducted approximately 1.8
million investigations concerning the
welfare of nearly 3.2 million children
only about 896 000 or 28 percent of
these children were ultimately found to
be victims of abuse or neglect 71
percent or roughly 2.3 million children
were thus subjected to state-mandated
thorough investigations involving at a
minimum interviews examinations and or
home visits in circumstances where the
state in the end could not show that the
children were unsafe and in need of
rescue
investigating these children is
consistent with the state's highly
precautionary strategy to remedy the
nation's maltreatment problem however
from the perspective of the investigated
child the process is not so clearly
meritorious indeed despite the
authority's best intention intentions
the process can be harmful in two
related ways first
the investigations undermine the
fundamental values of privacy dignity
personal security and mobility that are
protected by the fourth amendment and
it's critical that uh the in this regard
that the fourth amendment uniquely has
been interpreted to recognize the
child's own individual interest in these
values by guarding her right also to be
free from unreasonable searches and
seizures both inside and outside the
family home
second depending upon the child
and the nature of the investigation the
process can cause severe emotional and
psychological damage ranging from
temporary discomfort to significant
long-term harm end quote
this account is nearly 20 years old
today based on national numbers reported
by the states and published the u.s
department of health and human services
administration for children and families
children's bureau the figure has held
steady in recent years at around 83
percent of child abuse and neglect
investigations are unfounded and
shockingly among investigations started
with an anonymous tip the number of
false or erroneous reports jumps to a
whopping 96 percent
the reason for this is simple if you and
i were to suspect child abuse or neglect
was going on we would have no hesitation
to provide our name or contact
information we would do anything to
protect a child but when you bring in
anonymous reporting there is no such
protection anonymous reporting
encourages false reports by disgruntled
neighbors political opponents scorned
lovers and ex-spouses there's a term for
this that we've heard weaponizing the
system
hb 1612 will end this loophole in the
law it will end the system from being
able to be weaponized against innocent
families importantly also there's an
equity issue it will protect families of
color as studies have shown through the
federal government and others that
children of color are removed from their
families at far higher rates than white
children
passage of hb 1612 into law will protect
innocent children and families and it
will allow dcyf to focus on children who
are truly at risk for abuse and neglect
thank you
are there any questions for mr estrada
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um
i'm going to kind of uh
re-ask the question that i asked before
about
other states and how
those other states if you're aware
have
punishments for people
trying to weaponize the dcyf system
require confidential or do some allow
anonymous reporting and then
if it is found to be
malicious then
dcyf could hol hand over the phone
number and a tape recording of it to the
police and the police can do an
investigation to see if that um
if they can identify that person and and
charge them i would refer you to a law
review article by dale checker it's her
name was spelled
c-e-c-k-a and i can provide you later
that it's 64 catholic university law
review 51 published in 2015. dale
checker was then a professor of law at
the university of richmond she's now the
assistant attorney general for the state
of georgia and she went case by case
through every state 40 states in the
district of columbia allow by statute
anonymous calls to their child abuse
hotlines there are 10 states that have
confidential reporting all these 10
states however do have procedures in
place where they'll encourage
confidential reporting so give us your
name and phone number but if the caller
refuses to they won't push it and
they'll still accept the report all 50
states do have state laws that make it's
a misdemeanor to make a false report the
the difficulty however is
if you're accepting an anonymous report
it's difficult to prove it i think we
heard from the um
or difficult to find who made that
report
we heard from from the head of dcyf that
new jersey for example records these
calls
no one's really spending the time to do
voice analysis or find that out so again
it's very very difficult to find if
you're accepting anonymous reports who
actually is making those anonymous
um follow up
yeah
can you um i guess just
it sounds like um
not all of the states that have
um
from from your testimony it sounds like
not all the states that have a
misdemeanor punishment um
uh require confidential reporting some
do still allow anonymous reporting even
though they have that punishment is that
right
your testimony am i understanding that
correctly correct yeah so again 40
states allow in their code anonymous
reporting 10 states will will encourage
the confidential reporting it's in their
state code but the state children and
welfare cps will still accept these
confidential reports although they have
the misdemeanor charges for a false
report
it's very difficult to actually
prosecute those because there is just no
information that's provided
thank you
are there any further questions
representative long
thank you thank you madam uh
chair
uh thank you for taking my question
thank you for your testimony
so
is your testimony that there are no
states that
require
um
your name
when reporting
their courage and some absolutely don't
great question representative so 10
states do require it in their in their
state reporting and again this was dale
checkers um
analysis state by state but of those 10
states that that have a confidential
reporting statute as opposed to
anonymous they still by policy will
accept an anonymous report
it does provide greater protection
though and i think one of the benefits
of hb 1612 is just that fact that the uh
that the dcyf person who's answering the
phone on the 24 7 anonymous tip hotline
or or hotline will give that warning
that if you file a false report you
could face penalties that'll that's
something that that would that would be
unique um in in state codes and i think
would be very helpful in reminding
people
this is not just something this is this
is something if you're if you're filing
a false report it can come back to bite
you
follow up for me
thank you
so would this be the wouldn't if this
were to go through would this state be
the first that does not allow
anonymous
it would be it would join the other 10
states that by statute don't um accept
anonymous the the
it i guess it would depend on on how
dcyf would implement it the way it's
written it doesn't in my mind prohibit
dcyf from still encouraging the
confidential reporting so there may
still be an avenue where it would where
they would take down that that
allegation i don't see it prohibiting
that um but it would
so it wouldn't make new hampshire alone
in that case it would become the 11th
state um i think it would significantly
reduce the concerns of of that we've
raised of anonymous reporting very good
thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you next is um
is it russian
um chester to speak in support of the
bill i'm going to ask you to keep it to
three minutes because we're really
hi my name is russ ann chester i
wanted to come forward as a former cps
worker here in this state as well as in
another state
my experience in this state although
it's
older now
as a worker we have always always wanted
to know the name just in case so and i
thought i understand the whole issue
with anonymous reporting and we don't
want to um to do any kind of chilling
effect i understand that completely
there's an easy fix to that we have an
800 number that goes to central intake
that's an essential intake can take that
information and keep it and if they
don't want their information disclosed
they put a star on it or something so it
doesn't go to the district office so the
person that's doing the investigation
doesn't know what's going on but if we
need more information because
to be honest with you we're a small
state by the time we get out there they
usually know parents usually know we're
coming um
if they're trying to hide something they
can
i can honestly tell you i think a lot of
our
devastating results of child illness and
or child abuse and neglect in the state
is because of anonymous reporting we are
one of the few states that allows um
everybody in this every adult in this
state is a mandated reporter
um that being said with that kind of
responsibility
with that kind of of of
responsibility comes some sort of
accountability
so what happens when an anonymous report
comes in the person goes out
sometimes if you get
a ton of anonymous reports
from the same
you get on on the same family those end
up starting getting screened out
and then
people aren't being going out aren't
going out to see those children so
that's a second problem with the
anonymous reporting thing
because the person that's taking that
call and at central intake is not
necessarily always that same person
um
so
that being said i really appreciate this
bill for that reason
confidentiality is important and should
be protected but the children and
families who are being reported on
should also be protected and anonymous
reporting does not allow that
i would argue that there's a lot more
anonymous reporting than just the angry
parent um when i was doing child
protection in this state and i saw a lot
more of it in arizona
there is a huge issue with
i've gotten into a conflict with you
for whatever reason and
i know you have kids so i'm going to
report on you
um
i do have concerns about the gal part
and the reason for that is gal um most
of the guardian item first of all we
have a huge shortage of guardian items
second of all most guardian items are
attorneys um they have done some small
piece
of uh understanding
child family relationships but they
certainly aren't social workers and at
the same time i would hate to see
as the representative from dcyf said i
would hate to see child protection
workers now taking on the responsibility
of deciding what's in the best interest
of the child when they specifically are
there for abuse and neglect
thank you thank you are there any
questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much
up next is catherine shea
to speak in support of the bill she's
asked for 10 minutes i'm going to ask
you to cut it to 5 because we're really
short on time
good morning committee thank you for
allowing me to speak
kate or catherine shea from goffstown
new hampshire
i have to admit that i'm a bit rattled
coming here today because i'm a parent
advocate that speaks regularly in
education meetings but
i came to relay my own personal
experience which
sort of brings back some ptsd for me
a six-year divorce
that was incredibly painful and nasty
and didn't need to be that way and the
process that we went through did not
protect us in any way
so i'm here not to talk about pointing
fingers at one group or the other or
should we do this or that
in support of this because it's doing
something
no sorry about that um
thank you i didn't mean to like shine
the light in your eyes um
so so i normally go to a lot of uh
hearings to speak on behalf of children
i'm an educational advocate and a state
volunteer parent of four three of them
have autism there are a lot of parents
like me and you're not seeing a lot of
parents out here today right but it's
because
we don't even have the wherewithal to
you know we're trying to make it through
every day right and a lot of us end up
we have special needs kids we end up
going down this path of divorce it's
unfortunate it's really sad but because
of other supports and services we didn't
have we find ourselves on that path
and then we find ourselves further
attacked by maliciousness so when i
heard this bill was coming up i was glad
because i heard of other states that did
have some stop gap measures from just
a free-for-all right like somebody was
speaking about your your neighbor or
somebody it's at the school and you're
trying to do the right thing for your
child get an iep and the next thing you
know somebody's called in some
ridiculous complaint
and um
it's hard for me to know where to start
with this but i wanted to speak from the
heart to you guys today to say i'm in
support of it um i have heard arguments
for safety and for you know all these
other reasons and as i'm helping one of
my children learn about the constitution
i have to go back to something that
benjamin franklin said about safety and
i'm not going to go through all these
quotes but if we give up a little
essential liberty to purchase a little
temporary safety we deserve neither
liberty nor safety and in our world
today we've given them up okay so the
people out here like me there's not many
that can come into these hearings
because we're like
treading water just trying to you know
make ends meet and help our kids the
best we can we have sometimes special
needs kids we're taking advantage
believe me of every opportunity out
there
but when people get away with things
like this and there's no consequences
it's like i mean i i've never had high
blood pressure in my life as soon as we
hit you know the hurdles with my kids
special needs and we were fighting iep
battles and then the divorce battle and
then
we even had a guardian ad litem and
none of that helped to protect us
um
and you kind of left sitting there as an
adult almost 50 going
wow i was really disillusioned i thought
all this was here to protect us but
we've given it all up over time
so i am in favor of this i do think
there's some i work in i.t i work with
you know process re-engineering kind of
things
if we can fix this process put in some
stop gaps we are going to prevent
disasters from happening and to
happening happening to good families
right and we can use those resources
instead of them being directed to attack
people from malicious means
to worthwhile endeavors to help children
like harmony or others right that need
the help my mother was a social worker
so i'm coming from a perspective that
understands social work she was a public
school teacher social worker i have two
sisters that are public school teachers
i get it but sometimes our processes
aren't working exactly as they were
intended right maybe we in the in the
guys of safety have given too much and
we haven't put in the stop gaps that we
need to
have those checks and balances that like
i said as i teach my son about the
constitution they were originally
intended to be there but somehow we
found ourselves even in the court of law
somebody can make something up and
there's in family court no one to hold
them accountable for you know speaking a
lie that's not even something that's
prosecuted anymore in family law cases
it's like
whoever throws the lies at the wall fast
enough and gets them to stick gets heard
and that's exactly what happens in these
cases especially in divorce where it's
the person out of the gates thinks they
can just lob an attack and that's what
happened to me to the point where the
person reneged and they right in front
of the social worker said i just you
know i met he made up something he's i
misunderstood uh you know didn't really
mean it you know and i'm thinking well
there's got to be a consequence it's now
happened two almost three times
so at what point is there a consequence
or to the school nurse who decides to be
nasty because she says well you know
your son's going to the hospital but i
didn't get medical records well hello
lady you don't get medical records those
are protected so which what does she do
she picks up the phone i'm gonna get her
back
boom
you know and it doesn't matter how much
of it's unfounded doesn't matter because
it sticks to you
and and when you're a good parent
it does what i just it raises your blood
pressure it nearly gives you a coronary
to come home and see something you know
tacked your door
it's not right that people are getting
away with us and i think that's all
we're asking for as parents is for some
justice
some real consequences if we have to
face consequences in the adult world for
speeding or this or that like certainly
there should be a consequence for
something so serious that someone's
children could be put in jeopardy
especially mine with special needs i
can't even imagine
you know so i'm here to speak despite
you know it is a scary thing
and and as i said i had to face the six
years i got dragged through something
that i didn't want
but um
it's not enough against them this is not
a parents against ecy if this is a
got some problems with the process so
like what can we do to fix that
and that's all i'm here to say so thank
you for your time do you have any
questions
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um if
there's a lot of discussions about gals
and um
confidentiality versus anonymous
do you think that
if those things were
stripped out of the bill and it was just
a a punishment on the books and the dcy
of people on the phone saying if this is
false there could be consequences do you
think that's enough to
to
say that this is moving us in the right
direction and then we could come back if
there's still issues to
maybe enhance those um
those protections further let's say if
if if dcyf has
um
multiple cases that they're saying
um you know they're anonymous and we
weren't able to prosecute them
um
but we know that they were abusing the
system so we need some more you know
strength in that aspect but
do you believe that it's necessary right
now or do you think that um we could
take this
a baby step and it doesn't necessarily
need to be all or nothing in this case
thank you i think it needs to be bigger
than a baby step because we kind of have
the baby step now if you were to get
your records you can i mean some names
are redacted and whatnot but you can
essentially figure out
who is saying what you really can it
doesn't you know it's not rocket science
but what i do think is there's too many
people hiding behind layers of
confidentiality or not and
i could say the word being anonymous um
you know for an example in one of my
situations and the person knew somebody
on the inside and they used a mental
health worker so not only are they
anonymous but they're hiding behind a
mental health worker now so you got two
layers like there's there's multiple
layers of protection but for the person
on the outside of this
there's none so i think we have to do
better than a baby step
for the gal
you know having had gone through that
process myself i mean i heard someone
else speak about this they are attorneys
um you quickly learn and going through a
family law case that you're just you're
you're paying for the
vacation home for your for the attorneys
essentially right they're building a
home at a i mean my case alone thirty
thousand dollars both sides easily
without even paying the gal you know and
we are not a family of means you know so
it's devastated us but the gal was an
added expense and it you know honestly
it was something i was advised by my
attorney to get and it didn't come back
to help me one bit
there was no added value you know i'm
not necessarily opposed to gal but
adding overhead for the sake of overhead
or oversight i'm not a big fan of that
so i think we need other measures in
place
and not just rely upon somebody to
enforce it or this department to do that
or adding another position
there's got to be some incremental you
know warnings along the way i do know
wisconsin will send a warning i believe
when somebody
makes a complaint and they send them
back a letter i believe with something
effective be aware that this is a
punishable offense if you're making a
false complaint so i mean there's
there's other options out there but i
don't think i think it needs to be
stronger than just
you know the change in um the level of
information that's
allowed to be provided
are there any further questions
all right seeing them thank you very
much
and up next we have jr hall to speak in
support of the bill who's asked for five
quick minutes
for the record j.r hole former state rep
former member of this committee
i ended my service in 2018 i'm here to
speak in favor of house bill
1612.
um i'm going to skip over section one i
have no
no opinion on that my wife and i are
happily married
and with four children and
um
this seems relevant to divorce
proceedings so i'm i can't
make an opinion on that i want to speak
to sections too and following
um
i'm living through this nightmare
because of a gag order there is very
limited information i can share about
what's going on in my life
i can tell you this started as an
anonymous report
at some level
okay it was not hard to figure out where
this started
in my personal life
okay
confidential
allows for
someone to come back later on and figure
out where this started and depose them
in a courtroom if necessary
there's a huge difference between
someone making hearsay evidence that
starts an investigation and then someone
being able to to call on that person to
substantiate that
our constitution is extremely clear part
first article 15 that so no subject
shall be held to answer for any crime or
offense and in some cases dcyf
is pursuing both criminal activity
okay as part of their jurisdiction okay
crimes against a person that are
significant enough that someone should
go to jail and then they are also doing
civil level cases
where
it could almost be a matter of
parenting i will go back to reading the
constitution no right shall we answer
for any crime or offense and the civil
stuff falls under a fence until the same
is plain fully and plainly and
substantially informally described to
him right
and
it goes on to talk about the fact that
we should be able
to have that person right to be able to
as i said i i
because of a court order i'm limited in
what i can share right now but i can
tell you confidentiality is what drives
some of the corruption into this system
that if there was more transparency
about what was going on
as representative long said it might
diminish a little bit about the
reporting there is that is a a
legitimate concern
however
if there is real harm
the person who's making the the
mandatory the mandatory reporter the
person who is calling into the system
has a reason to want to make that phone
call there's not going to be a concern
i would also like to say
i have
i have one concern on section four just
from a straight drafting point okay and
this is the last line
okay under no circumstances shall the
identity
of the complainant who made the report
of suspected abuse or neglect in good
faith or pursuant to rsa 169 c29 be
released
that's overly broad it should be
released publicly at a minimum right it
should be allowed to be given to the
respondent so that the respondent in
these cases can talk to that person or
there is no way to have justice
if only if one side says hey i've got
some information
but i'm not going to be able to share it
with you tell you i just know that this
person has done something wrong
that does not give us the transparency
and the justice our system deserves
i would ask that this court i'm sorry
this committee
been to court a lot um asked that this
committee passed this bill i don't know
about section one i'm not going to speak
to section one but sections two through
the end with the with the one exception
of the change that i asked for
about that last line be passed i would
go further that the language should be
even more clear that in
that the confidential name could be and
might be released
to the respondents if this matter is
found to be founded and to go forward
into a court proceeding because at that
point the mandatory reporter should know
that they're going to be potentially on
on a witness stand
but if they have real facts that they're
reporting then they should be allowed to
make right they should be willing to
stand up for what they believe to be
true if they're not this might be and
this is how this whole thing filters out
the alleged
right the false allegations they're not
going to stand they're not going to be
willing to go to court over a false
allegation and put themselves in risk of
perjury so
i thank you i again ask that you support
this bill um and that would be it okay
so i have a quick question
so who is responsible
if that name gets out and that person
ends up killed
by the person i mean it's real domestic
violence is real
right and if that name gets out
someone's going to get killed and i
would also bring up you know
a certain case that's in the media now
i would take one look at that person see
a teardrop
tattoo and
be an extreme fear for my own safety if
my name got out there as the reporter of
that abuse to them
so i i that's that's where i want to
know who is then liable when that
someone gets killed
well if someone is killed the person who
did whom who committed the murder is
liable right but i think the point here
is
there is there is ways under the
confidentiality statutes of c25 right
169-c 25 and other places under 170.
okay to keep certain information within
what happens to the court but the
respondent should always be allowed to
know who made the report and if if if
the respondent is the one who commits
murder right
that person is going to jail
but would you not agree that the state
by
by giving that name out i
if there was an actual report
where there was harm done right criminal
harm in most cases but is what the basis
is
and
that mandatory reporter be it a person
might be at a public official be it a
medical professional whoever right be it
i don't know a teacher or a librarian or
something okay
if they actually had real concerns
there's lots of things they could do if
they knew their name was going to be
out there they could in fact ask for a
protective order to make sure that this
that
the the respondent right
is not allowed near them there's a lot
of things they could do to protect
themselves if necessary if there is true
harm and i think that's the thing is
statutes are hard to write i sat up here
for eight years okay because
there's a lot of the one percent on both
extremes in terms of the cases that make
it hard to write legislation because on
one case
and
with good
i like your question because you could
have a case where someone is fearful of
their life in terms of if i share this i
know
i don't know i know my cousin for
instance might come back and try and
harm me i'm not saying that personally
i can see that concern especially where
there's there may be a mismatch between
genders right it may be a female who's a
concerned about an overly aggressive guy
right the typical way someone sees this
i can see that but i can also see where
someone hides behind the current
confidentiality sorry the the current
anonymous statutes
and aggravates a divorce that's going on
in family court or
another type of case
and
i can say with absolute certainty i've
never talked to dcyf they've never
talked to my family until
eight weeks ago
the the first case record was of this
case there was zero before that
okay but i can also see what's going on
in terms of how they pigpiled on top of
that in terms of other reports that have
nothing to do with it
i just the anonymousness and fortunately
the judge was willing to say something
like no i want the names of everybody
released in this case so the respondent
can at least figure out whether they
need to be on the stand in question
so
my point here is
as you guys draft this bill understand
the bill has to cover a very broad
spectrum and the false reporting is the
concern right now and how do we mitigate
that how do we make sure that if someone
is maliciously accused of a crime or of
abuse or neglect that they have a chance
to cross-examine their accuser
appropriately or at least in a
deposition they may not be able to do it
in a court but their attorney could do
it in a deposition
okay
are there any further questions
representative long
thank you madam chair thank you mr hull
um
i mean do you agree that malicious or
intent to harm is a high bar to prove
thank you for the question
representative long i do malicious is is
a very high bar to
um to point to
and if i can follow up
um
in in section four
you're asking that um you're asking that
there be no
um
no not anonymity on any reporting is
that no no no that's not thank you for
the question um no what i'm saying is in
lines 27 28 okay
that currently the way i would write
read this okay
it would prohibit that information from
being shared at all to anybody within
who's a party to the to the case and i'm
not sure that that is actually what the
bills was intending to do right be
released means publicly as opposed to to
the parties in the case
and i think
if you were to do this
right you could inadvertently wipe out
some of the other things you're trying
attempting to do
right so it's just it's it's a clerical
thing more than an intent thing right
very good thank you
representative yokela thank you and
thank you for taking the question it
seems to me that um
suggesting that
there is more than
one reason for collecting this
information this
it seems to me that the that the
information is being collected in this
bill so that
um
if there was malicious intent with the
reporting that that could be filed and
charged
against that person
and
you seem to be suggesting that
the
[Music]
that the person that is reporting
the
the things that they saw to dcyf or
have reason to believe to dcyf
that
that is
um
that the purpose of getting that
information is so that that it can be
used in
in court whereas i think
and you were talking about responding to
the person essentially alleging a crime
and um
it's my understanding that
that dcyf takes in that information and
they go and do the research and they are
the one that actually go to court and
allege the crime not the person that
that um
uh originally
said hey something might fishy might be
going on here is that your understanding
that is
correct let me restate right in most
cases it is dcyf that is
the reason
that i can bring up another case right
when it becomes a medical neglect issue
okay
the testimony of the initial reporter is
is significant and important which is
different than let's say
i call right hypothetically again i
called because i was concerned about the
screaming i heard at my neighbor's house
my neighbors are fine there's no
screaming going on but right there's a
difference there but i think taking the
information on has multiple values the
most important of which is if there if
dcyf needs to follow up with that person
later on all that information is
excuse me
secondly
if this matter moves forward because
there is some basis to move forward
there is the opportunity for the
respondent in these cases okay or if
it's a if it ends up being a criminal
case because
the alleged abuse is is
is greater than just
civil in nature the defendant
you would have a chance for that person
who's on the responding end to be able
to cross-examine them in a court
okay because there may be first-hand
evidence of that initial reporter that
has to come out
as opposed to the person who's pursuing
the charges right dcyf acts kind of as
the prosecutor in this stance
as opposed to the person who was the
firsthand witness they are a secondhand
witness in all they take the information
they they write a report
much like the police do but they were
not the first hand witness so there
might be a need to have a discussion
with the firsthand witness later on
thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you members okay so i'm going to close
the public hearing on hb 1612 and i will
open the public hearing on hb 1280 and i
have no pink card so can someone just
introduce this bill really quick for me
because it has to be introduced before i
can even
take a it's terry royce
but
it's uh 1280. you don't even have to
speak to it you just have to introduce
it
okay representative spelaine thank you
very much
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
uh i am introducing
hb 1280 on behalf of terry roy the prime
sponsor because he could not be here to
do so
so i'm going to call on lisa lipkin
who's asked for eight minutes
i'm going to read a statement if i read
a little quickly it could be less than
eight minutes okay
um
honorable members of the committee thank
you for taking my comments and support
of hb1 1280. for the sake of time i
won't take a poll but i imagine that
many of you are parents and those who
are not are beloved aunts uncles and
family friends
from that vantage point you understand
the unique nearly boundless love you
have for the children in your lives
this love is universal
lifelong and pervasive
it is the norm
in the mental health field it is well
known that the loss of a child is the
most catastrophic trauma that could be
fall apparent
conversely for children the loss of a
parent is emotionally tantamount to
their own death
therefore any externally imposed
separation
i.e termination of parental rights must
be considered in this scale
the fact is most parents dearly love
their children and do everything in
their power to help them grow and thrive
are there exceptions of course
but there are fewer than you might
imagine
i ran some numbers
in 2019 the u.s census stated that there
were 73 73.1 million children in the
united states
according to the u.s department of
health and human services in that same
year there were
656 000 cases of abuse or neglect in our
country
now let me be clear
every single incidence of child abuse or
neglect is one too many and thoroughly
unacceptable
but here's the important perspective
those numbers calculate to .008
percent
that means less than one percent of u.s
children are actually abused or
neglected
a little bit of a relief
so let's now place that knowledge around
the current pressure exerted upon
parents to vaccinate their children with
an experimental shot that has no
long-term safety data and is showing
alarming side effects including death
it must be said that all vaccines carry
risks including the risk of death
the independent peer-reviewed data in
support of not vaccinating children is
enormous
but i am not going to focus on general
vaccines right now i'm just going to
focus this testimony on the covet 19
vaccine
more numbers
a harvard study done a few years prior
to the onset of covet 19 concluded that
somewhere between 1 and 10
of adverse reactions are reported to the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
this is the cdc's own database designed
to track vaccine injuries
given that harvard study we can be
certain that the following numbers
presented by wisconsin senator ron
johnson and a press conference this past
november are well below the actual data
calculated over 25 years
the total annual adverse events for the
flu vaccine
averaged 7596
with 76 deaths
total deaths from the flu vaccines over
25 years of flu vaccines
less than 2 000 deaths again every death
is a tragedy but less than 2 000 deaths
contrast this with 10 months
10 months of the covet 19 injection
adverse events reported
are 818
forty four this is in november
that is eight one hundred and eight
times that of the flu vaccine
with seventeen thousand one hundred and
twenty eight deaths
that number of deaths is 225
times higher than the annual number of
deaths from the flu vaccine
this injection is a completely different
creature
as it relates to children
dr robert malone is a u.s virologist and
immunologist who has dedicated his
professional existence to the
development of mrna vaccines
in december 2021 he made a public
statement
the entire transcript is here and i can
give you guys for copies
but i'll just be a little briefer and
dr malone says
before you inject your child a decision
that is irreversible
i want to let you know that the
scientific the scientific facts about
this genetic vaccine which is based in
the mrna vaccine technology i created
there are three issues parents need to
understand
the first is that a viral gene will be
injected into your children's cells
this gene forces your body your child's
body to make toxic spike proteins
these proteins often cause permanent
damage in children's critical organs
including their brain and nervous system
heart muscles includes blood clots their
productive system and this vaccine can
trigger trigger fundamental changes to
their immune system
the most alarming point about this is
that once these damages have occurred
they are irreparable
you can't fix the lesions in their brain
you can't repair heart issues
you can't repair heart tissue scarring
you can't repair a genetically reset
immune system and this vaccine can cause
productive reproductive damage that
could affect future generations
of your family
the second thing you need to know is
that this novel technology has not been
adequately tested we need at least five
years of testing slash research before
we can really understand the risks
ask yourself if you want your own child
to be part of the most radical medical
experiment in human history
one final point
the reason they are giving to vaccinate
your child is a lie
your children represent zero danger to
their parents or grandparents it is
actually the opposite their immunity
after getting covet is critical to save
your family if not the world from this
disease
the risk benefit analysis isn't even
close as a parent and grandparent my
recommendation to you is to resist and
fight to protect your children
in conclusion
99 of parents do not abuse or neglect
their children
neglectful harmful parents are not the
norm
rather it is the norm that parents work
overtime to protect and provide for
their children
and those parents those parents should
not have to fear that a government
agency who is often not well informed
not aware of the dangers of vaccines and
who does not love or even know your
child could jeopardize your parental
rights over this issue
or worse could literally take your child
away
while you are desperately trying to
protect that child
exactly the way any fully informed
loving parent would
exactly the way each of you would
i'm encouraged and optimistic that this
bill is being presented and i look
forward to seeing it pass thank you
thank you are there any questions
representative long
thank you madam chair thank you for your
testimony thank you uh so i i mean this
isn't covet specific so
that just kind of i i'm
more specific on the um
on on the i mean currently there are
vaccines being used
i haven't heard of anybody's
termination of parental rights for not
getting the other vaccines wonderful so
i'm looking to identify the problem and
the need for this bill
i mean has there been termination of
parental rights for current vaccine
requirements oh i don't know
i mean i i'm just speaking to the bill
okay great i don't know the history of
the bill i'm actually fairly new to new
hampshire so i don't yeah
all right thank you okay
thank you very much thank you
up not next is stephen dave's to speak
in support of the bill
uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak uh yes i'm a husband and father of
three children
um
i personally am
pro
pro choice for vaccines
i choose to vaccinate
however i would not under any
circumstance want somebody's children
taking from them from them if a parent
chooses to use their right of conscience
to not vaccinate their children
instead this is something that we can
use persuasion rather than coercion to
convince them
specifically the new hampshire
constitution guarantees our right to
privacy and our right to conscience
so
it's it's very disheartening
that you wouldn't support a bill that
would infer the rights of the parents
and the rights of families
it is the role of government to protect
our rights
and if if at any point you felt that
this bill would protect the rights of
parents
then you should support it um however if
you feel that it is the role of
government
to have the power to take away people's
children from them for doing what is
against their conscience
then i would please ask that you
question your position
because it is the role to protect our
rights
so thank you
and if you have any questions go ahead
representative petrigno
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
so struck throat is pretty common among
young children
and
if it's not treated with antibiotics
rheumatic fever which can damage the
heart is a potential cause
inflammation of the kidneys
is another cause
would it be appropriate for parents to
exempt their children from
antibiotics
and if so
then when we make a comparison to
vaccinations
wouldn't it be neglectful to put
children in harm's way not to get
vaccinated or to get antibiotics or for
that matter any medical treatment if the
parent so chooses would that be
neglectful
i appreciate the question
it is definitely moving the goal post
off of the bill at hand which is
specifically limited about vaccinations
um but at the same time this
i would challenge you to find parents
that don't want the best for their
children more so than the people sitting
in this room or any rooms in this
building
parents spend
sleepless hours thinking about what's
best for their children
are do they get it wrong yes sometimes
they do personally i'm also against
spanking and smacking your children and
there has been several countries that
have made that illegal as well however
it's perfectly legal in all 50 states to
hit your children every single day if
you don't like what they do and i don't
believe anyone on this board thinks that
parents should lose their parental
rights for spanking
but there are several some do right um
however many don't i'm sure as you're
aware and there are
what's that i don't think i said that
oh okay i'm sorry right here yeah
there's a difference of opinion right so
the same is true for what are the
ramifications for medical procedures the
same is true for what are the
ramifications for smacking and spanking
your children there's negative cognitive
problems there's behavioral problems
that could cause
sociopathy right which are
societal problems that could result in
mass murders mass shootings
which are far worse than somebody
getting sick and dying because their
parents chose not to vaccinate them or
give them antibiotics
i believe that this is the role of
medical professionals primary care
physicians to talk to parents and for
parents to find primary care physicians
that they trust as i've done i found
primary care physicians that i do trust
and
and that is how this relationship works
so
i hope that answered your question
representative long
so uh thank you for taking my question
thank you for your testimony
um i i'm still trying to identify the
problem uh with respect to spanking
there are parents that have been
terminated uh because they've it was
claimed to have been abusive
um so i'm still trying to identify
where
i mean what i'm hearing is that
we should be putting in these bills i i
don't agree with spanking so i should be
putting in a bill to stop spanking
um
so i i don't uh yeah i i'm just
trying to look for where we where this
bill is needed is that you know what
what is the problem that this bill needs
to be
uh this bill is a chance for
representatives to stand with parental
rights
um
most of you some of you may be parents
thinking of being parents are
grandparents
and i'm sure you have an idea of what
you want for your children and your
grandchildren and you hold your idea
very highly because you've probably
thought about it a long time but at the
same time if you believe that your
neighbor should be doing something you
have a conversation with them you tried
to persuade them and this gives the
opportunity for persuasion rather than
coercion it bans coercion of of dh
dhhs
from holding something over a parent's
head saying if you don't do this thing
that we say
which
may or may not help the child it
possibly likely would help them but
we're not sure
um and specifically it's it's difficult
so if we do reference like the last
testimony if we do reference this
specific covet vaccination which is i
think is probably the motivator for the
bill right more so than any of the other
vaccinations it's difficult to trust the
pharmaceutical companies who tell you
that there have been zero deaths during
trials and then from freedom of
information act of requests from
december 1st 2020 to february 18th it
turns out there were over a thousand
people that very likely could have died
from the vaccine after previously they
said that there were no deaths and then
after requesting more evidence from
their trials they say it'll take 75
years for us to release all the
documents to the public
so there's there's already this the
scenario of protection for
pharmaceutical companies specifically
passed in 1988 with the child vaccine
safety act which prevents pharmaceutical
companies from being held personally
liable to lawsuits
it's a really weird scenario to think
that you can make a product
force it on people and then you can't
sue them if you're damaged from it
there's very few other industries where
the tort claims the right of protection
from damages does not exist so
specifically that's why this bill should
be supported because of the existing
legal environment set up in the united
states to protect the pharmaceutical
companies from from lawsuits
okay thank you
are there any further questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you up next we have mary
smith who has asked for two minutes or
less
thank you chairwoman and the committee
what this bill addresses is that parents
have the right as stewards of their
children to make medical decisions
for their children not the state
this bill seeks to affirm that basic
notion that governments are instituted
to safeguard rights not demolish them
to
speak to representatives along
representative long's point
about what is the need for this bill if
there have been no recorded instances of
anyone's parental rights being taken
away
on the basis of
vaccinate i would say
that
i don't have those
figures or numbers in front of me
and that's an excellent point and
it speaks to
the
sort of underlying point of the
legislation that i think other people
have tried to communicate
adequately and maybe they haven't
communicated adequately is
we're not sure we don't know
but it is evident or clear
that
um recently
in public discussion has included
whether or not parents should be
considered
negligent
in their care of their children if they
don't take steps
that would safeguard
the the health and the life of their
children and one of those steps could
plausibly be vaccinating or not
vaccinating their children
um
so
given that vaccination can lead to
a child
not contracting a disease or not
contracting a disease as severely as
they might without vaccination i think
that is the impetus that is the reason
why
parents are interested in this that this
bill has
been submitted that i'm here to testify
for it and so were
other parents
before me
so hopefully that clarifies all right
any questions
representative ocala thank you thank you
for taking the question
um
all right
is a vax vaccine um
the medical decision regarding vaccine
um
unique
in
recent
history
examples of
judges
taking a vaccine to be
on parole
or
deciding who has parental custody based
on
whether or not they
are going to provide the vaccine to the
child are those unusual
cases that maybe we would not have seen
before covet and therefore this this
bill would not um
have come up
in less
presented uh come to the forefront of of
um i guess our societal
consciousness
uh
to answer your question i think the
yes
that
this
has been
unusual and probably infrequent
before kovid but now
due to covid and coveted vaccines and
the controversy and the different
feelings that different parents have
about what is best for their children
that now you are going to be seeing
many more instances
where you have an entirely plausible
case where people can go to the state
like um
[Music]
parents in a dispute can go to the state
and say
well
this parent who i'm fighting against for
custody of my child
has clearly shown negligence or
disregard of the health of my child
because
they have prohibited or blocked us being
able to get a vaccine or have them be
vaccinated and so it may well be the
case as as you pointed out that
because it wasn't uh
in the public consciousness as as much
that these cases may have happened but
they may have been infrequent
and
may not have been the cause for
legislation in the past but are now
because
it is such a sticking point it is so
it is
at the top of mind for so many parents
and so many legislators so
are there any further questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much up next is russ and chester she
didn't put how much time but you got
thank you madam chair thank you
committee members um i just wanted to
say that this isn't new
when i work for dcyf there are some
people for whatever reasons
they choose to not want to
necessarily follow the vaccine process
they have been accused of being
neglectful and or medical neglect
specifically
and they have come to the attention of
dcyf
right here in new hampshire in some
instances they have a good reason
but
they still are not always successful so
i had one person who is absolutely
convinced that her
two-year-old round of shots
caused autism in her son
i'm not going to be able to convince her
otherwise
she had another baby after like two
years later so
she refused to get the other one
fully vaccinated she just wanted she
only wanted to spread it out she was
still brought up on charges of abuse and
neglect she still went through the
system her children were put in foster
care so this is real
um
and yes covid has
opened
pulled the curtain back but the other
thing that i would say is because
there's there's not a lot of statistics
because unfortunately child protective
services hides behind a veil of
confidentiality
that again speaks to it's very easy to
say
oh it's not a big deal in our state
because no one can talk about it the
other thing is is that i know right now
there's there is a situation where and
it was with regards to the covert
vaccine but a parent felt very 50 50
custody one parent had
um
felt very strongly that they wanted
their child vaccinated the other parent
felt very strongly that they did not
want their child vaccinated so they
brought it to the courts and the judge
ruled
that child has now suffered
some
[Music]
symptoms from the vax from the coven 19
vaccine vaccination
don't know if it's it's going to be
temporary or permanent however
something like this would protect
um
protect children and parents the bigger
thing that i see in that two things
where their parents are fighting about
the vaccine issue that child is being
that child is being maltreated because
they're not they're not able to
work with their parents and come up to
some kind of solution
so
that being said that's the that's why i
like this
bill coming forward because it is
something in our state and it goes back
to any kind medical treatments if you
have a an experimental medical treatment
you know same thing
difference of opinion
so
thank you are there any questions
representative long
thank you uh
madam chair thank you for your testimony
so you're telling me in new hampshire
somebody refusing to get vaccinated
is medical neglect and they took their
children and put them in foster care
that was the case yes
that actually happened that was a that
was a
real life it hasn't happened recently
but we've done so much to deteriorate
our parental rights in new hampshire i
wouldn't be surprised if it's happening
okay today thank you
so speaking of parental rights would you
not then say that the other parents
parental rights are being deteriorated
if they choose to have the if they want
their child to be vaccinated
and and i agree all right should be
considered both parents rights and the
children's rights so it is a sticky
wicket i'm not saying that child
protective services shouldn't have been
involved what i'm saying is is that
because of because of this type the lack
of this statement there's not
there's
one parent's rights are being
outweighed over the other this would
allow
people to make a decision because in
some cases
one parent's right they may have a very
good reason that that woman had a very
good reason for not wanting her child
vaccinated you know in this situation
the parent that wanted her child
vaccinated um they're not involved with
dcyf
the parent that wanted the child
vaccinated
is based on the information she has and
the one that did not based on the
information they had the appropriate
thing would would be to do in that
situation is to create a mediation
and to try to see if we can come to some
kind of an agreement
thank you representative yokela
thank you thank you for taking the
question isn't um
shouldn't
um
or doesn't the
decision
about the cost-benefit for each
and even the history with the child
or or previous children as you as you
said um
way into the decision of whether or not
a a parent might vaccinate their child
and
and maybe even the timeline for which
because it seemed to me that so
there has been some discussion about
whether or not
um spreading out the vaccines over of a
longer period of time or letting the
children choose that at you know an old
and
an older age might be more appropriate
in that individual circumstance
do you believe that that should
um be
um
that there is a range of of
choices
that
may be
argued and valid
and
it's not
uh
it shouldn't really be a deciding factor
about whether or not they the
children are removed from the parental
care yes thank you and i thank i
appreciate the question so the re the
reason why
i'm speaking on this is because it's the
most egregious
form of of uh termination of parental
rights is devastating it's devastating
for the biological parents it's
devastating for the child and it's
devastating for even this child
protective worker that's been involved
so that's why i like that it's just
specifically for termination of parental
rights this doesn't prevent someone by
making appropriate decisions for their
children
nor does it
force
any coercion on either side because you
still have that process that you can
work through through with the
termination of parental rights that's
after that's after it's been quote
unquote proven through the court process
that it's not in the best interest of
the child to maintain a relationship
with that parent
thank you i
like follow-up thank you
yeah it's it seems like you're um
in that last statement where you're
talking about um
that parental ending terminating the
parental rights is essentially saying
it's not in the best interest of the
child to
be
um
to maintain that maintain that
relationship and
and your your
testimony to this committee is um
that
while that vaccination and decisions
about that is
is not enough of uh
of
a detriment to the child to warrant uh
the removal of that relationship
vaccination in them itself i do not
believe it should be um unfortunately i
just think that that's what's happening
thank you
seeing none thank you very much
okay so i'm going to close the public
hearing on hb 1280 and we will be back
all right good afternoon um
i'm gonna
open the public hearing on house bill
and we're calling representative dave
thank you as you said my name is
dave testerman i'm a representative for
franklin hill
in
ward 2 of merrimack
county
today i've got a bill
to introduce
to
prevent
abuse of children
i'm not here to argue about whether you
can
give
various toys or clothes or dye your hair
whatever you want to do that's not it
i'm talking about chemical and physical
abuse of children
uh who will
have a lifelong dependency either on
drugs
or a lifelong
change if they've had a
a physical
operation
uh
the the rsa or excuse me the bill
merely adds a definition to abuse it
says if you drugs or physical
therapy to your physical changes to a
per
a child it's a it's called abuse
and that's that's just it
so any questions
up next is stephen scar to speak in
did i pronounce your name wrong
scare
okay steven scare 111 east hobart street
in nashua
and i'm here to speak in favor of the
this bill
the the strongest advocates of putting
some some limits on
child transgenderism you'll find if you
go to the subreddit for people that have
gone through d transition and right now
it has almost 26 000 members
and something that they emphasize is
you can't tell no one has any way of
telling who's going to regret
the
what's happening with with the gender
blockers or cross-sex surgery or double
mastectomies later
there there isn't any clear science
behind it i realize some people are
happy with it
they but they repoint point out that
being that young they were
unable to make informed decisions
and they tell
a common story for young women is that
they had trouble fitting in with other
girls they didn't fit female stereotypes
they were drawn into transgenderism by
social media
media and peer groups
and then just rushed through
medicalization by therapists who didn't
who didn't explore other
one woman
laura reynolds
she's a detransitioner she has a child
now she regrets not being able to
breastfeed and of course a change to her
voice and some of the other changes to
her body
she says children don't have free will
they'll believe anything if you tell
them they can change their sex they'll
believe you
and just briefly one other reflection
that's running on the subreddit page
expressing frustration from someone who
went through
child transgenderism herself
why have trans activists pushed so hard
for immediate medicalization of anyone
who is experiencing even minor forms of
gender discomfort dysphoria encouraging
a lifetime of doctors blood tests scans
injection surgery even more surgery
instead of just trying to talk therapy
first would it be ethical to staple the
stomach of a 14 year old anorexic shot
so they can't get gain any more weight
even though there's nothing wrong with
them physically and the problem is all
psychological
seems insane but that's exactly what
we're doing to trans kids permanent
changes from a problem that isn't real
that isn't even real a lot of the time
sex can never be changed and no matter
what surgeries and unhealthy medical
procedures you do to people it will
never come close to the bodies given to
us at birth
yet we throw all that away because of a
thought that we were born in the wrong
body
how can it be wrong if it's perfectly
healthy and functions by itself without
need for medical intervention doesn't
make sense
so thank you very much for this
opportunity to speak
up next is chris urchill
do they pronounce that right
thank you chairperson members of the
committee my name is chris serchill i am
an attorney with glbtq legal advocates
and defenders which is new england's
premier legal advocacy organization for
lgbtq equality
and i'm here today to speak in
opposition to hp 1651 i'd like to start
by drawing the committee's attention to
house rule 36e
which states very clearly in the second
year session no bill or resolution shall
be introduced if it is substantially
similar to any legislation that was um
indefinitely postponed or voted in
expedient to legislate
by the house in the first year session
this bill is identical
identical indistinguishable from hb68
which was introduced last year and it is
in blatant flagrant violation of the
house rules thank you for bringing that
to my attention i didn't even think of
that because the whole you know the
whole first year was
very confusing um so thank you for
bringing that to my attention you're
welcome um
i would like to go on to say
that uh transgender people in our
community um they're assets to our
community
they are our neighbors they are um
parents they're participants in our
workplaces and our communities and our
libraries they volunteer they are
friends they're family they're
everywhere
and um they can be they can be really
productive and helpful and wonderful
contributing members of our community
but only if they have the tools that
they need to succeed and if we deny them
those tools to be successful happy
healthy contributing members of our
society when they're children they have
little chance of being successful as
adults
gender dysphoria is a serious medical
condition it's widely accepted by every
single medical
organization in the country
and in the world in fact um that that
gender dysphoria it's i don't need to
rely on a subreddit to to to make my
case every major medical association
agrees that gender dysphoria is a very
serious but very treatable medical
condition
um the the the um sorry the condition
manifests because of an incongruence
between a person's assigned sex at birth
and their gender identity um
treatment for gender dysphoria oh so
sorry not just any discomfort with one's
gender qualifies as uh clinically
diagnosed gender dysphoria there's
criteria that are laid out in the dsm-5
it's been available for years to any
practitioner to understand what the
diagnostic criteria are when someone's
diagnosed with gender dysphoria there's
medical standards of care that are
applied to treat somebody with that
condition and those include different
forms
different forms of treatment which which
vary from social transition like using a
different name pronouns um in in
different settings dressing a certain
way uh there's hormonal treatments
there's surgical treatments there's also
legal avenues that people can take to
get updated identification documents to
reflect who they are all of those are
under the general umbrella of of gender
transition which is treatment for gender
dysphoria it's extremely effective um
and and um
and every single medical organization
agrees i'm not a doctor so i'm not
speaking from that perspective but i can
guarantee you that there is no major
medical association that disagrees that
gender dysphoria is highly treatable and
the treatment is uh
gender transition which this bill would
turn into a criminal act um so so it's
it's it's um it's such an extreme way to
to react to that at the same time that
we're having this hearing in an hour
there's going to be um a hearing to
on a bill by the same sponsor to repeal
the ban on conversions okay but we're
we're sticking to this one yeah yes you
know i understand i'm bringing it up
because the conversion therapy ban that
this uh that this legislature passed
back in 2018 was meant to address the
fact that there are people who to this
day despite mounds of evidence um you
know to the contrary there are people
who who to this day believe that the
correct way to treat transgender and gay
youth is to try to convince them or
force them to change their gender
identity or change their sexual
orientation that persists to this day
and that's just what this bill is is is
is manifesting right now and just for
broader context we are in the midst of a
massive attack on transgender youth
across the country
bills in every single state legislature
that are aimed at harming transgender
youth and this is just one more of them
and um i hope that this committee votes
decisively like you did last year 15 to
nothing unanimous it i hope that happens
again this year
thank you so much for listening to my
testimony i'm really happy to take
questions if anyone has any and
thank you for your time
okay are there any questions represent
represent
no
we're going to take a a five minute
break because i wanna i wanna check on
um
the policy of with the house rule
so um give me five minutes and we'll be
back
at
131.
um
recently
yes
um
hopefully
me
uh
yeah
okay we are back
so i made them aware i mean now that
it's a bill we have to continue but um i
made them aware and they're going to um
look into it and stuff so
thank you for bringing that
to our attention
okay so up next is holly stevens
to speak in opposition to the bill she
has written testimony
um representing naomi
that sounded weird i didn't say it right
nami
that's okay
chair rice and members
of the committee
on behalf on behalf of nami new
hampshire i'm here to speak in
opposition to house bill 1651 adding sex
reassignment to the definition of child
abuse for the record my name is holly
stevens and i'm the director of public
policy for nami new hampshire
specifically
i wanted to talk about the high risk for
depression suicide attempts
and suicide deaths for individuals who
identify as transgender
by way of background
i'm sure if you've heard
our past executive director speak ken
norton he's talked a lot about nami new
hampshire's connect suicide program
it's a program that's been designed as a
national best practice
in suicide prevention intervention and
postvention
and has they've used it to train in over
40 states and 35 tribal nations
nami new hampshire and the connect staff
serve on numerous national and local
work group committees including national
prevention
the national prevention lifeline as well
as new hampshire's legislatively
established
suicide prevention council
just wanted to provide the background
about the extensive
knowledge that nami new hampshire does
for individuals in our state that are
ages 10 to 34 suicide is the second
leading cause of death
and it's only the tip of the iceberg
when you're you know looking at suicide
attempts
and the human and economic impacts of
suicide deaths and attempts is is very
significant
a very a small but important
subgroup of
these individuals
are people that
deal are dealing with gender identity
issues
and there's an emerging body of research
that's showing showing that trans uh
people
are less likely to attempt suicide
um excuse me
i got that completely backwards they are
more likely to attempt suicide
than their peers in the general
population
young people who are non-gender
conforming
are also at a higher risk
a 2021 study indicated that people who
go undergo hormone therapy or gender
affirming surgery
have significant reductions in
psychological distress including
there have been previous studies on
suicide rates of individuals who
identify as
uh transgender
that show that some of the unique
factors that contribute
um to this pot to
that this this this population faces one
of those factors is a lack of family and
adding hormone therapy and gender
affirming surgery to the definition of
child abuse takes away a parent's right
to support their child as they see fit
as i you know previously stated
a lack of family supports contributes to
the increased risk of suicide
in young and the young transgender
population
and if passed house bill 1651
would be harmful to the mental health of
these individuals
and as i previously mentioned
in those studies it is likely to lead to
an increased risk of depression suicide
and suicide attempts
and because nami new hampshire is
committed to addressing suicide as a
public health issue and reducing the
incidence of suicide thoughts attempts
and deaths
we respectfully urge that this committee
vote inexpedient to legislate on
this bill thank you for taking my
testimony
thank you are there any questions
all right seeing them thank you very
much
up next is emma savini to speak in
opposition to the bill she does have
written testimony
good afternoon chairperson and honorable
members of the committee my name is emma
savini i am the children's behavioral
health policy coordinator at new futures
new futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all granite staters
new future strongly opposes house bill
1651 because it creates a disincentive
for parents to seek medically necessary
and potentially life-saving treatment
for their children and youth by labeling
that treatment as abuse
gender reassignment therapy is not child
abuse and this bill would have
far-reaching and devastating
consequences to all new hampshire
children and families to understand the
far-reaching implications it's important
to distinguish between the terms sex and
gender sex is typically referred to as a
combination of physical characteristics
typical of males or females on the other
hand gender identity refers to a
person's internal sense of being male
female or for some people a blend of
both or neither
further still gender expression is how
one of them how people choose to
express their gender to others such as
clothing haircuts and other
some children show a great deal of
distress when they are
forced to
conform to the gender roles
that they are signed based on their sex
at birth
some children may even experience a
condition known as gender dysphoria
which other
test
speakers have spoke on today
the american academy of pediatrics
strongly endorses the use of gender
affirming care when treating children
who are suffering from gender dysphoria
um gen
depending on the child's age and the
level of distress they're in
gender affirming therapy can be um
a range of treatments it can range from
you know talk therapy as men mentioned
or it can
range all the way to gender transition
and it's important to note that before a
child reaches puberty gender transition
is typically limited to just those
social changes such as using different
pronouns allowing a child to express
their gender through clothing haircuts
etc
after puberty if a child
continues to go through gender affirming
care
it's important to have early
interventions in that care to
reduce the negative effects that have
been mentioned by nami
rejecting a child's gender identity and
denying them gender affirming care
leaves them at risk for
an increased risk for depression
self-harm isolation post-traumatic
stress incarceration homelessness and as
nami mentioned suicidality
suicidality is one of the most serious
elevated health risks facing gender
transgender people
again the american academy of pediatric
pediatrics emphasizes that discouraging
or shaming a child's gender identity or
expression can harm a child's social
emotional health and well-being and may
have lifelong consequences
early intervention and treatment can
combat those negative implications
while gender affirming hormone therapy
is what we traditionally think of as
gender affirming care
every child is unique and treatment can
vary from individual to individual those
decisions should be left to the child
the child's parents and the medical
professionals treating that child
by adding this uh gender affirming
treatment to child abuse you're removing
that parent's ability that child's
ability and the medical team's ability
to make decisions that could have like
lifelong implications on that child's
life
failing to support medically necessary
treatment for children transgender youth
and families could lead to more costs
for the state in the long run because
the state will have to pick up the bill
for children who have those lifelong
consequences
we should be supporting our youth to
achieve physical and mental well-being
instead of creating barriers and
dampening access to medically necessary
treatment for a particularly vulnerable
population for those reasons new futures
strongly urges the committee to vote
house bill 1651 itl i'm happy to take
any questions
all right seeing none thank you very
up next is jennifer smith to speak in
hello
thank you for taking my testimony um
maybe i'll be shorter than three minutes
given all the other testimony um
i have sent you an email this morning
with a brief testimony but i just wanted
to kind of rebut some stuff make make
things clear i am transgender
i know lots of parents of transgendered
children
nobody is rushing anybody into anything
i also know gender therapists
so
the idea that was
put out there
that there's going to be lots of regrets
there's only one good study about regret
from the european union where a lot of
gender reassignment has occurred
and they found in a very large sample
four percent with regrets
those regrets were not because they
weren't transgender it was because they
couldn't find social acceptance
they're difficult sometimes
i was pretty fortunate that even though
i struggled with it there were some
other aspects of my life that made it
easier and in the 1950s and 60s
it was all called transsexual and i knew
it wasn't that cause i'm attracted to
women
so
you know it it's kind of and i'm also
very athletic and very competitive and
those things were things that you
weren't supposed to be if you were a
girl so even though i felt from earliest
times that i can remember
desire to dress in girls clothes
to play with the girls
i got schooled into being different and
i succeeded because of those other
things
i have relatives who
have transgender children
the thought that they're allowing a
child
to keep up with peers in
high school
by going on hormone therapy would be
class child abuse even though
this was
something that was approved by
medical doctors and therapists after
careful
yes talk therapy
making sure that this was not some
strange thing for a psychotic
young person
those things do happen i happen to have
practiced at new hampshire hospital as a
part-time physician part of my career
there are some psychotic individuals who
for some reason get a fixed illusion
around gender
that doesn't seem to have the usual
aspects of gender dysphoria
but that's
unusual both among mentally ill people
and among the rest of the population who
have gender dysphoria
and i know a lot of people with gender
dysphoria at this point
so
i i think you know
the issue of well it never got voted on
last year so i guess they're treating it
like it had been tabled and you're
allowed to bring back a table bill in
the second year of the biennium that's
all i could figure
it didn't get voted on there were a
number of bills at the end of the
session
that never got brought to the floor
so i
right
i do hope that you will repeat last year
and put it on the consent calendar
itl
and that we will be done with the
nonsense again until the next
session and maybe this particular rep
who doesn't seem to have anyone else who
wants to bring the bill with him
won't even be here who knows
so
please i tell this bill
are there any questions
up next is anna mcpherson
okay
my name is anna macpherson however
that is my legal name at school and a
lot of my other clubs i go by andrew
i am a transgender strange gender
citizen here of new hampshire
i currently attend londonderry high
school
but i'm here instead to
oppose this bill because if
when i heard of this bill i had to leave
my class to cry because if this bill got
passed
i would not be able to
have surgery that would make my life way
more fulfilling as a transgender
individual
um
as of for detransitioners
a lot of people have come up to me and
wondered
not wondered um a lot of people have
questioned me about
detransitioners and according to a study
of two that twenty eight thousand people
surveyed
who were transgender eight percent of
them had de-transitioned at some point
but uh sixty-two percent of the eight
percent had only temporarily
detransitioned and a lot of that happens
before
sex reassignment surgery
um so like more social transitioning
where then they can
go back to
being on track to getting their body as
their mind
their body corresponding to their mind
um
yeah like yeah you're doing a great job
don't be nervous this is the first time
i've ever done this so you're doing
transgender people both
on the binary
and gender non gender non-conforming
face a higher risk of suicide and
self-harm
i should know i have self-harmed
um i have no of i have a lot of friends
who are both lgbt and
homosexual and transgender transgender
a lot of them
they're the reason i
was able to socially transition in a lot
of aspects of my life they were the
reason i was able to come out to my
parents
my dad is here with me today also in
opposition to the bill and i'm super
super super thankful for that
and to say that he could get arrested
because it would be illegal for me to
get
drugs that would make my
to make my body match my mind is
absolutely ridiculous
and if we're worried about what drugs
we're injecting into children i
shouldn't be able to take my anxiety
medications i shouldn't be able to take
tylenol or any other drugs because
they're going into my body and it's
going to create a chemical imbalance
the anxiety medication helps me live my
life and if starting testosterone which
is what trans trans men and trans boys
go on to make their voice deeper
and change their body a little is going
to make my life more fulfilling
it needs to be legal thank you
okay are there any questions for andrew
all right seeing them thank you
and up next is dave
mcpherson to speak in opposition to the
thank you very much um i probably will
not take the full two minutes but my
name is dave mcpherson i am andrew's
father
the thought that sexual reassignment
surgery can be considered abuse to me
is
i don't even know i don't even know
there's a word to describe it to me
personally i don't know that there's a
bigger sign of love that a parent can
give to their child than to have an
educated decision with a medical with
medical professionals of this is the
right course that we need to take for
you
it's not abuse it's love and i'm just
going to leave it at that thank you
are there any questions
all right seeing them thanks so much all
right so i'm going to close the public
hearing on house bill 1651
and then i'll open exec session on house
bill 1561
all right so this will be the executive
session on house bill 1651
desimone do you have a motion thank you
madam chair i do i move in expedient to
legislate
on house bill
1651 fn
and yes i'll speak to my motion and
that's seconded by representative long
so i would just like to say that i don't
believe it's the state's prerogative to
get involved in this this is a decision
made between a parent a child a doctor
and a mental health professional
and
we should not be
making life more difficult for families
who are already going through
a difficult time in their lives trying
to find out where they belong in this
crazy world
so
that's all i have to say
i also
wanted to comment on that you know like
they said
that that community is suffering so much
so i
make it harder for them they need all
the help that they can get and the
is there any further discussion
all right
representative de simone i want to um
just back up what uh if
the chair and representative levesque
said i don't understand it but if i was
a parent
just like mr mcpherson i'd make myself
understand it
for the best interest of my child and
i'm not going to be the legislator that
against a criminal i'm not i'm just not
it's not right
all right
is there anyone else
all right i'll have the clerk call the
roll
representative disamoom
yes
representative yokela
not here at the moment i apologize
representative nelson
yes
representative long
representative alessia
representative grossman
yes
representative levesque yes
representative petrino
madam
chair rice yes
motion carries
without objection
and that's a wrap for today
ladies
you